part of the problem is people are
thinking of it as a green revolution
because the thing that they would most
hate
is for us to solve a problem of climate
change
to create a world that looks exactly
like it does right now but without
climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is a writer
and youtuber marlon baker welcome to
trigonometry thank you it's great to
have you on the show before we get into
the conversation and it's going to be a
very interesting one
tell everybody a little bit about who
are you how are you where you are what
has been your journey through life that
leads you to be sitting here talking to
us
well it's probably a journey of four
parts which is
first of all was campaigning because
when i was a
a youngster we literally thought that
global nuclear war was about to break
out any minute
so that drew me into campaigning which
led to me living for a period of time in
a plastic bag outside the main gate of a
nuclear missile base i mean we've all
been there exactly exactly
you were against i assume right against
the global nuclear war i i thought it
was a bad idea
to be fair and that much was certainly
true
i would say that i was right and wrong
in equal measure during those times but
that's a longer discussion
the second stage then was politics
because i got fed up of campaigning
which is about saying no to stuff all
the time and i thought surely we should
be able to say what we actually want to
happen instead we want to say yes to
something and i was under the strange
impression that you went to politics for
that sort of thing i know i know i was
naive and youthful so i ended up in the
green party became co-chair of the uk
green party for a while
uh once i realized that that wasn't
totally an organization that wanted to
make itself fit for changing anything
very much i ended up in the lib dems for
a while
until the point when i realized that
actually i'm not built for politics i'm
a pragmatist not
not remotely ideological
um i don't enjoy factions i'm always
looking for
the objective pragmatic solutions
so they need to be good people in
politics but i realize that wasn't me
and i have to say that i don't think i
feel a huge amount of fellow feeling for
either of those
parties in their modern incarnation i've
been a floating voter ever since third
stage then is corporate social
responsibility
which was
talking to major corporations
some of the top ftse 100 companies about
their environmental impacts about their
social responsibilities not to be
confused with woke corporations there's
a distinction that is important but
probably not very interesting
and
that was with business in the community
which is a membership organization that
has a lot of the top chief executives
engaged so that was an interesting
eye on that universe
of people making decisions for huge
corporations with lots of power and
influence and how sometimes change goes
through those sorts of spheres
and then finally now here i am with the
youtube channel where i stepped away
from that
and ended up going back to those
principles of becoming curious again
about well what is really true about
what's going on
having started the channel thinking i
was going to be carrying on doing what
i'd always been doing which was
supporting change makers who were
working in different spheres
ultimately i started to do a few
debunking videos and then got really
curious as to well actually hang on a
moment i thought this was going to be
debunking this but the closer you look
at it actually with some real substance
to this argument the lizards really are
in charge yeah
so
i refashioned what i was doing into
stepping aside from the polarization and
just asking the questions about what is
what does the research really say
and does it actually mean what people
popularly would have you believe and
that has been fed into all sorts of
topics and issues largely where
the scientific realities bump into the
political sphere which is increasingly
happening as we all know and actually is
going to become more and not less of a
factor of the next few decades so it's
where all the difficult dilemmas lie all
the grey areas that i find so
interesting and
you've got a great youtube channel and i
was watching it over the past couple of
days for doing research and you did this
brilliant video that really hooked me in
on safetyism
and the role that safetyism is playing
in our society and before when i was
talking with constantine we realized
that it also linked in with the main
topic that we're going to be talking
about which is climate change so
could we have first of all your thoughts
on safetyism and how we've seen it
rapidly progress from the moment when
you were a child in fact yes
it's interesting because
over the first
10 20 years of my adult life it was
always a running joke
about you as society changes you you can
tell how old you are by how often you
moan about how things are different to
how they were when you were younger
and there was always a running joke
about health and safety you know health
and safety was always a thing that had
gone mad sort of thing
and yet
beyond that when you looked at where we
are now and the mindset that we have now
you realize well it's actually gone
beyond a joke and it really struck home
for me first of all when i did a video
where i was comparing the current
pandemic the recent pandemic shall we
say with the 1957 asian flu
which was
not identical but was broadly in the
same zone in terms of the the harm the
health harm that it created but of
course how society reacted to it was
completely different
mostly we just carried on with life as
normal there were some adaptations that
people made but the interesting thing
was it wasn't a political issue
it just wasn't i mean there was a
vaccine that was produced relatively
quickly and i think government support
helped that to happen there was an
election in america the next year i
think and the incumbent lost but that
was nothing to do with it it was not a
political issue at all
and the reason for that of course was
that
people just didn't have the expectation
that government was there to keep them
safe from a virus
you know disease happened
and obviously first really serious
disease came along then people would
have to organize a way to deal with that
if health services might be over
might be overcome then of course the
government has to put resources in to
make sure that doesn't happen but
otherwise people just didn't think that
that was what it was there to do
now that has changed obviously and all
of the lockdown fever that we've seen
over the last couple of years
and the
fact that no leaders
even those who started well with the
pandemic have ended well
you know not even for st lee jacinda you
know they are now seriously
unhappy there as well not even there
have any of the leaders come through the
whole two years
well and arguably that is because the
expectations now on what the government
can and should provide for you as an
individual has just gone beyond the
basis of what it can actually deliver
and this has
gone hand in hand with this view that
it's there to keep us safe yeah the
first job of government is to keep us
safe
and that was always the case that was
the old hobsyan your contract with the
state the leviathan state was that it
was there to protect us from each other
and ourselves
we were talking about was you want to be
protected from foreign enemies and from
criminality in your own exactly that's
it exactly that's what he was talking
about absolutely yeah but over time that
has become layered up and layered up and
particularly then in the aftermath of
world war ii when we had the creation of
a welfare state and everything you had
more and more layers for own on
all of which we then we simply absorbed
into our expectations of what government
can do for you
and so now we have ended up in this
position where we have been officially
wrapped in cotton wool for for so long
that we have become fragile people
you know whereas
before we dealt with adversity by
training ourselves to be strong in the
face of adversity by teaching young
people how to cope with difficulties and
difficult situations and
they read to kill a mockingbird because
it made them feel uncomfortable because
those i was part growing up confronting
all of these things
and i walked to school and
nobody thought anything of it probably
they were kind of hoping i'd get lost to
be fair
that might actually just be me
nevertheless no nobody much commented
about in fact the stat that came out of
when i did the research that video was
saying like i can't remember the exact
number so i said 78
of kids walked to school when i was
seven or eight year olds walked to
school when i was seven or eight
and now it's like eight percent i mean
just astonishing and and of course
that's because the traffic got worse we
had all the newspapers telling us about
stranger danger and people they wouldn't
let their darlings out because they were
terrified that there were predators on
every street corner
and
the process has is just as we have seen
it
media
hyping up dangers because it feeds
clicks which feeds their advertising
model which feeds into a
terror mindset amongst the population
and then looking to authority to defend
themselves from that and that has
created a
a weakened dependent mindset
rather than a strong resilient
citizenship and that is a real problem
for us
well politically it's a big problem
because one of the consequences
that seems quite inevitable to me out of
this sort of approach is that means the
government has to do more things and if
the government does more things it means
there are more errors of your life that
the government's involved with and i'm
not someone who thinks the government is
has no role in society at all of course
it does but the problem is the
government is a very blunt instrument
for dealing with lots of issues or you
see it in the conversation around
freedom of expression for example the
government can either ban things or it
can allow them it can't have you can't
have the new ones conversation about
well you are allowed to be a dick but
maybe you shouldn't be right the
government can't do that so if we make
the government regulate every element of
our relations every element of our
behavior every element of our safety
you are going to end up with a sort of
at best soft authoritarianism eventually
that is one of the dangers for sure and
and you can add to that the fact that
governments are actually just not very
good at doing lots of things
you know why did we get such a rapid
vaccine roll out well in this country is
because they took it out of the
bureaucracy's hands and put it into a
small panel which brought together the
private sector who are used to doing
things quickly and to scale
and they managed to do a much much
better job and then as soon as they
handed it back to the bureaucracy of the
state it all gummed up again so you've
got both the tendency of governments to
want to push you to to comply
you know if you won't
you know if you will insist on getting
fat then they'll try and nudge you and
if nudging won't work they'll push you a
bit harder and then you marry that with
the fact that they're actually not very
good at executing
and so that you get the worst of all
worlds in that sort of sense but we do
have a real danger ahead of us because
as we are moving more towards these big
global issues that we're facing
that tends towards the technocratic
mindset in terms of whatever solutions
and how do we deal with them
they tend towards authoritarian
solutions
now it doesn't mean say that governments
will naturally give in to that you know
i don't see that the likes of boris
johnson or the likely successors have
that as an ambition particularly
but there is a dynamic that you have to
actively oppose you actually have to
push the other direction not to drift
that way
and i don't see that they have a
sufficient vision
currently to do that
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthony has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
i was going to say man the thing that
worries me is we're talking about
authoritarianism and a few years ago i
would have scoffed at that but what we
are seeing is a kind of soft
authoritarianism which ties into the
whole safetyism issue because you look
at what the american government are
trying to do to joe rogan and trying to
silence him by the time this goes out he
could have been assassinated yeah
exactly r.i.p joe but
that would be in bed anyway that would
be in bad taste if it actually happens
yeah we'll have to cut it out exactly we
hope you're well made mate
but
if you look at what the american
government are doing they're trying to
silence him they're trying to
de-platform him
and they would argue that they're doing
that because they want to inverted
commerce keep people safe
by not by so that he can't spread his
inverted comments misinformation and
what we're seeing is his safetyism as
far as i'm concerned being used as a way
to control us it's soft authoritarianism
do you agree melon
uh i do and i'll tell you why it's
happening i think
which is that we have now come across
two big issues
where
it's very easy for the elites if you
like the the government but also the
mainstream media types and
various people in the same orbits
to see that there is a right thing to do
and people need to be persuaded to go
along with it so both in terms of a
pandemic and now also in terms of
climate change
you have got the situation where the
population need to be persuaded to do
the right thing
and that has turned what used to be
streams of communication streams of
information from government
where
they were there to tell us what was
going on
that has now become streams of
what some would describe as propaganda
but in any case it's campaign messaging
when i first started out dealing with
climate change issues and you know i've
always half of what i ever dealt with on
the corporate responsibility stuff was
showing companies how they had to
respond to the climate change agenda
it's thing i've been dealing with for
decades however extinction rebellion as
mad as a box of frogs so
you know i did a few videos critiquing
the extreme campaigner end and some of
the things that they were demanding
which just didn't make any sense
and i had various people saying well
what you say is absolutely right it's
just not helpful to say it at this point
and i have heard that so many times
since from other things you know i
kicked back against the insect
apocalypse because the language being
used there was overblown apocalyptic
language again and when you looked at
the research it didn't support some of
the top-line messaging yes there were
you know problems with insect declines
and the research shows that but not what
was being claimed and then again someone
came back and said
everything you said was correct
scientifically all the papers you cited
were correct you didn't
misinform but it wasn't helpful
messaging
and and it just underpinned for me now
how much of this has turned into
campaign messaging this is the problem
and this is why people then start to
distrust what they're being told you
know why did we get some stats during
the pandemic and not others because some
stats were considered to be helpful in
underpinning the message that says you
should be worried about this and
therefore you should comply with the
measures that we put in play and some
were less helpful in that although they
were arguably more helpful in
understanding what the heck was going on
which some of us really wanted to do
what you're really talking about marlon
is is a very good point which is
it's very sneaky what they've done what
they've done is they've they've traded
the signs for public health
right these are two very different
things science is about finding what the
truth is public health is about getting
people to do what you want right
and they've said if you're questioning
the public health
you're not following the science yes
right these things are not the same
thing and climate change which is the
issue that we were originally going to
talk to about and let's get into it now
because you've kind of brought us there
very neatly seems to me to be exactly
the same right because what you've got
on the one hand is a bunch of people
running around
gluing themselves to trains
going absolutely apeshit over every tiny
little thing that happens and the
science isn't really being talked about
properly what you've got is that extreme
end on one end and there's other people
who who think it's not happening and i
look i'm not a scientist i don't know
which one of them is right i'm just
saying that i think
the messaging is much more like public
health than it is like science the way
we're having the conversation about
climate change
so
what is the truth about climate change
because you know we've had roger halen
from extinction rebellion on the show
we've had patrick moore who thinks it's
all a bunch of horseshit we've had bjorn
lombok he thinks it is happening but
it's not that big a deal like where are
you on that yes
so
this is one of the frustrations if you
get involved with this because of course
what you have with most of those
characters there is that you have people
on the opposite extremes
and people often say well to get the
balance of the issue you you talk to the
one side and then you talk to the other
side the vast majority of this issue
lives in the middle and that's not as
simple as that but nevertheless let's
start there so the core science the core
science is the planet warming is the
human burning of fossil fuels causing it
is pretty clear and
i mean there are multiple streams of
evidence that all point in the same
direction so when scientists say the
science is settled they're talking about
back that basic core which is supported
by multiple streams of evidence all of
which are very very straightforward and
hard to argue with and most of the
skeptics now bar a few of the out and
out you know the scientific community is
engaged in a conspiracy against us all
types
um
they they largely accept that much the
question then really comes through
so what so what does that mean for
what's going to happen in the future and
particularly then what does that mean in
terms of what we should do about it
and
have a problem with climate change is
that people conflate the two
so because the extreme campaigners go
around
trumpeting their version of the science
which is cherry-picked for the the most
doomest elements that they can find
then people will
confuse their messaging with
the scientific underpinning and so it's
very easy then if you're on
the a conservative mindset to say well
you know that is associated with those
wild-eyed loons therefore the whole
thing is wrong and that is a real
mistake what we have had in the uk over
the last couple of decades has been a
bit of a privilege in that both the
conservative end and the socialist end
all agreed on
the core of reality this is kind of
what's happening
and we could disagree about what we do
about it you know you can have a
conservative approach to tackling
climate change you can have a socialist
approach to tackling climate change
there'll be some commonalities there'll
be lots of differences that's what we
should be arguing about and fighting
about for sure let's deal with reality
and then argue like cats in a bag about
what we do about it fine and then in
america you had you know something that
was quite different and i tend to think
it's because al gore
arose as an early spokesperson and that
helped to polarize
it because he was a very partisan figure
but for whatever reason you've got one
side that is going
on on the extinction rebellion end of
the debate shall we say losing it
drifting in that direction and then we
got the other side that's been on the
trumpian end drifting in the other
direction and they can't even agree on
reality
which is a real problem now i always
thought that eventually
what we had achieved would start to
drift over there and moderate
republicans would start to pull things
in moderate democrats will start to pull
things in
i kind of think it might be happening
the other way around
[Music]
which is not good news really and part
of that is because of the incompetence
of our politicians
because we have a conservative
government that's not overly
conservative
and
what they are doing on net zero
has some good underpinnings but then
they are also generally incompetent i'm
afraid
and then you've got people within the
survey party who have been lumping in
the whole goal of net zero as part of
what they dislike in that and it's
creating then the same dynamic same
political dynamic that we see in america
that could play out well and it could
play out really badly and it's too early
to tell which way it's going to go man
i've got i've got this question which i
always ask people when it comes to this
on every issue you get your extreme on
on either side right and that always
happens whatever issue you take fine
why is it that you have the extreme left
same things you know we've only got 50
good harvests left the world is doomed
all the rest of it look they're entitled
to their opinion
maybe they're right maybe they're not i
don't know but then why is it that that
opinion is then funneled into our kids
and it's widely accepted and then the
media start talking about it and we've
got this generation of people who are
completely terrified because they think
one day they're going to wake up and the
world's going to be on fire well
probably why wake up
yeah well yes
this is a real problem uh you're
absolutely right and one of the things
that i discovered most
surpri that surprised me the most when i
started doing the the youtube deep dive
videos where i did the research on these
was just how often the campaign messages
that i had entirely accepted were were
standard and i've seen you know people
like michael gove repeating you know the
the government had entirely accepted so
you looked into them they fell apart 50
harvests
that has come from nowhere that that has
no scientific underpinning whatsoever i
think somebody tracked it back to where
it was and it came from a campaign thing
that was then misquoted and
just it's just not true simply not true
and yet it is repeated over and over to
the point where through repetition it
has become accepted as fact and then
michael gove will will repeat it because
he accepts that it's a fact and he is
trustworthy as well obviously obviously
he's such a good dancer
you couldn't
so this is a real problem because then
when you start to then take that as a
education process for for kids
then you are storing up these
deeply ingrained attitudes then that
become the next generation's instincts
their gut instincts about how they see
the world
that is one of our biggest worries
and of course it's always been the case
that the teaching community who do
fantastic jobs many great teachers in
there
as a whole they tend to
lean leftwards as as we know i would say
they're very left-wing well yeah and and
they were when i was brought up and
yeah who's attracted to that profession
most of us survive our upbringing
perfectly well and most kids are very
quick to spot
a certain amount of [ __ ] in their
education yeah there's a certain amount
certain amount you can just relax a
little bit
on the other hand when it comes to
something where
they are absolutely encouraging your
deepest insecurities and fears by saying
you know the climate is he's going to
hell in a handcart
there's one extinction rebellion person
who goes to kids and says you know the
issue isn't whether you're going to grow
old it's this is where you're going to
grow up
there's no science to support that
whatsoever but nevertheless this is
being
pushed to kids
have you seen millennials these days
they haven't grown up
we are millennials as well so i'm just
we're testament but look
you haven't quite addressed my earlier
question which i think is important to
do if we're going to have this part of
the conversation which is what is the
truth
about
how dangerous climate change is how
quickly it's happening uh what sort of
measures might be sensible to consider
in in response etc tell us that because
i think that's really the answers that
everybody's looking for is like we keep
being told there's a disaster
i don't think there is a disaster coming
in the next 12 years as aoc said we're
all going to die you know all of that's
not happening
so how urgent is the problem how big is
the problem and what are some of the
reasonable solutions that we might
consider to it
okay the reason why this is so confusing
is because
media has pushed extreme scenarios yeah
now the ipcc the body that collects
together the science and publishes it
reports every a few years
they produce a number of scenarios based
on what we do
because you can't predict the future
without
settling for how many fossil fuels are
we going to burn in the meantime
on the basis of what we kind of said
that we're going to do and the fact that
we won't do all of it but we'll do some
of it you know we're on a midstream
scenario
the extreme worst case scenario is what
tends to get often quoted and that's one
of these problems thing called rcp 8.5
as it was
and
that has been one of the problems that
always the click bait journalism will
talk about the extreme cases and so
everyone thinks that this this is going
to happen imminently
that doesn't mean
that there is no capacity for things to
go seriously wrong you know in a time
scale that we would care about yeah that
is absolutely a possibility
is it a high probability
not on the current basis but there's a
high probability that there will be some
problems that we need to deal with like
what
so
one of the challenges that we have is
that we have grown as a population onto
this planet
the population is starting to even out
but it is very very high for the
the state of planet that we have on and
we are currently now using all the
agricultural land as much
land space agricultural land as we
likely to have
ever going forwards
so we have hit a barrier there we can
make it more productive but we're not
gonna have any more
now the question is when you have 11
billion people as we will end up having
dependent on particularly a number of
bread basket regions that have to be
highly productive to feed all those
people you become very vulnerable to
shocks to the system because you don't
have very much resiliency left in the
system okay so you might be able to
create new agricultural land
further north
um as climate changes but then you will
lose some in the tropics as they become
less suitable for for growing we're not
going to have a lot more than we've got
so then if you get extreme weather
events which we expect to get more of
you may well have several years in a row
where you get severe shocks to food
systems which will then have
big knock-on effects throughout human
society those are the sorts of things
that are hard to map
because they depend on certain shock
events that will become more frequent
happening in an unfortunate sequence
and then the consequences could be very
serious those are examples venom courses
for things like the rising sea levels
and how much of human habitation is on
coastal areas and the amount of
disruption and cost that's going to
cause and so on i'm less worried about
that because that will be expensive it
will be a pain in the backside but
that's not life-threatening in the way
that some of those other sort of key
things are
now what should we do about it well net
zero is a policy goal that we absolutely
have to do
people
because ultimately
carbon dioxide stays around in the
atmosphere for quite a long time you
have to stop adding to the natural
carbon cycle
you know it is relatively in balance
without our contribution but so long as
we keep adding to it it's like an
overflowing bath you know you you put
more in and more in and it overflows
and
until we stop
adding to it then it won't stabilize it
will always continue now
time scales you know should be as fast
as possible but not faster and this is
where we get the overlap into
where people conflate the science with
the policy
because
we've had a committee on climate change
that have looked at all the different
aspects of the electricity grid and
industry and so on and what has to
happen to change all of those they did a
reasonably good pragmatic practical job
of looking at all of that and they came
up with this we could get to net zero by
2050
with our system the way that it is
working correctly so
not
laying waste to the economy in any way
shape or form which is what we want
maybe it's going to take a bit longer
than that i would expect it to take a
bit longer than that because
circumstances and humans imperfect we
will go there imperfectly and messily
and two steps forward and one step back
that's kind of how we are nevertheless
that time scale is a reasonable one if
we do it properly
another 10 years is reasonable if we do
it properly
the question is we shouldn't try and do
it faster than is feasible
and the danger is that people are seeing
it as a one variable problem just like
the pandemic they saw the pandemic was a
one variable problem covered cases and
we had to upend every single thing to
bring covert cases down which obviously
didn't work anyway
but in any case if the problem had been
maximum human welfare
then covid is one variable amongst the
number of variables and you're weighing
up the cost of the different things that
you're going to do about each of those
different things and maybe you'd have
ended up doing exactly the same
probably not but then at least you have
been weighing up those different factors
it's the same here
you know the single variable in this
case is co2 but of course it isn't
what we want is for human society to
continue to flourish for people to be
able to achieve their ambitions for
themselves and to live out lives while
preserving the natural world which keeps
us alive it's our life support systems
and also keeping the climate within
within the bounds
that will support our future going
forwards man what would you say to the
bjorn lomborg argument which is that if
we introduce this what's going to happen
is that energy prices are going to go
through the roof for the average person
that's going to give rise to ever more
populist leaders who will then push back
on it and then everything is doomed
i don't think you said that
you just started that
yeah i was nodding along
that's a tabloid journalist in me we're
all [ __ ] no
bjorn asked some very good questions
and um
the challenge i have with with
bjorn is is some of his evidence that he
uses for his specific answers but he
asks absolutely some of the right
questions and when i say that net zero
is a policy objective not a policy the
point is
there is no if you do this energy prices
will go up because there's 20 things you
can do
and if you do it properly you should be
able to do it in a way that means that
energy prices don't go up and when you
say properly what do you mean by that
well
so at the moment what we're doing is
we are
creating a
morality around the use of fossil fuels
which just says fossil fuels bad morally
bad
so you want to open up a new thing in
the north sea
for gas bad don't do it new coal mine
bad don't do it
and yet
if we are going to make any kind of
sensible progress through to net zero by
2050 or 2060
then it's a taper and we're going to be
using a lot of fossil fuels a declining
amount of fossil fuels over a period of
time now managing a declining industry
is perfectly possible and companies can
make perfectly good profit out of a
declining industry they've done that all
the time through history but it has to
be a managed decline
because as i think the head of bp said
to the cop 26 summit um if you try to
reduce the supply of the thing
before you've reduced the demand
then the prices go up and and arguably
that
it's not the only thing that's been
happening over the last year with energy
prices but it's certainly been a big
part of what has driven up energy prices
so this approach that the ideologues
have and sadly some of the ideologues
are in government as well which is
simply to push away anything to do with
fossil fuels rather than saying well
we've got a plan
over the next 10 years we're going to
use this amount of fossil fuels and it's
going to decline to that's going to
decline to that how do we supply this in
the most cost effective way in the way
that gives us most energy security and
so on and so on but isn't that the
problem alan that essentially you're
trying to reduce the demand for
something that will never be reduced
because of the population
for energy not for fossil fuel energy
but for energy
and you haven't got
a ready-made replacement that as cheaper
that's the beyond's point is you have to
invest in technology to make alternative
forms of energy cheap enough
that you don't then need the levers of
government to introduce it because
people are just going to buy this
cheaper energy wherever it comes from
but we don't have it yet do you see what
i'm saying yes although
i don't think that that is entirely true
in that you know certainly some of the
alternative forms of energy have become
cheaper
well
renewable forms of energy have become
cheaper so wind
wind and solar they're cheaper than than
burning yes
however
however the flip side of that is that
you need to they are intermittent forms
so you need to either be able to store
the energy that they create yes um or
you need to to find a way to to fill in
when when they're not so that's what i
mean overall as a package it's not
cheaper yeah at this point well we don't
have the way to make it work without
fossil whatever way you want to put it
it's not a viable alternative that is
cheaper as well if you are taking all of
the pros of all of the different energy
sources and all of the cons of different
energy sources and you factor in the
impact of the use of fossil fuels into
that equation then it drives you
necessarily to
forcing the pace on some of the
alternatives now some of the
alternatives are perfectly workable
and will become better we know if we
drive them so nuclear technology for
instance stood still for 20 30 years
because we got scared about it after
chernobyl and we froze the development
of that technology where it was you know
the existing nuclear power stations are
using 30 year old technology basically
that's reassuring fourth generation
absolutely
fourth generation uh nuclear solves a
lot of the problems that we were worried
about you know if something goes wrong
plants will shut down safely rather than
meltdown you know they don't create very
much nuclear waste in fact they can use
nuclear waste
old nuclear waste as fuel as with
anything if you work a technology to
scale then you gradually make it better
and you solve the problems
so if we work nuclear technology to
scale as the chinese are doing because
they can see that this is the technology
of the future
if you push yourself as pioneers into
that space you become the providers of
that technology to the world so then
what you've done by putting money into
it when it was less cost effective is
you've invested in the new technology
which you then recoup the cost of that
investment from by selling it to the
world because the world will go net zero
in a blink of an eye when you've got the
cost-effective technology that works but
how do you get that you get it by
investing in developing that technology
we already know that nuclear works it's
just that we've got ideological stuff
going on that has said that you know
even though we say there's a climate
crisis we're also going to be
anti-nuclear and you see that how could
you ever come to that conclusion if
you're simply thinking this is a
pragmatic problem to be solved it's not
it's an ideology that is driving these
why is germany shutting down nuclear
power stations right now and ramping up
coal when it says that it's going to be
a climate leader and by the way making
it extremely vulnerable to russia which
is why the current situation with
ukraine germany can't do [ __ ] because
they've they've closed all their power
stations and this is what
so net zero if it's taken as a pragmatic
engineering problem to be addressed then
there's a certain amount of investment
in technology that makes sense and and
you can plan in a way that will avoid
the problems of massive energy price
spikes and so on and so forth but that's
not how we're doing it we're doing it in
this weird ideological knee-jerk
technocratic way
where we
are making decisions based on how
difficult they are politically
more than we are about what's going to
get the job done
and that is going to lead to exactly
what you described what you ascribed to
bjorn whether he would have owned it
himself no he did say you're going to
get more bolton arrows yeah yeah you
carry on down there exactly that's his
exact words absolutely right because the
the technocrats who are pushing the
solutions at the moment are doing a
really bad job
of pushing their case
you know they are tending towards the
authoritarian which we don't like
and and telling you whether you can or
can't eat meat and all those sorts of
things
and
again if you were being pragmatic about
this you'd start by saying what do
people most value how do we reduce the
impact of those things
so people value travel
they value
what they eat and as soon as a country
comes out of poverty what do they do
they start eating more meat it's highly
prized highly nutritious
so you would start with a pragmatic
question of how do we reduce the impact
of the things that people value which
makes them more likely to come with us
on the journey that we need to go on
but that's not what we're doing at all
what we're doing is you know we start
this with an ideological preference
which is that people consume less they
travel less they drive less they eat
vegan they do whatever it is that we
think is a good lifestyle and what we're
going to do is we're going to cram that
down on them that is not a winning
proposition i would suggest and yet
the bbc you know
as soon as the bbc is talking about
climate change it takes seconds
before they have gone on to meat eating
or they've gone on to flying they can't
keep away from it
and yet there are massive impacts in all
sorts of areas that are
much more important to talk about
because there are bigger impacts that
have systemic
engineering challenges
that can be done at scale
why wouldn't you do those things first
why wouldn't you focus on those things
first
and persuade people that actually you're
working on their behalf you're working
so that they can have more of the things
that they value
long into the future and that their kids
can have those things as well and then
if at some point in the future if you
have to turn around and say we really
wanted you to be able to have this
but actually we can't
get this to work we can't get flight
that works anymore yeah we tried it for
20 years and we failed and you're not
going to be able to fly as much and
people say well we trust but you did try
i was going to say that now
because because
what they see is a bunch of people whose
first preference is to cram down
lifestyle restrictions on people first
preference
and it's also as well man you're not
going to win hearts and minds in doing
that and if you really want this green
revolution as it is to work you're going
to need you're going to need that you're
going to need ordinary people to buy in
but if you're saying to people oh you
can't fly and you're not going to be
able to eat me yet you see the elites
doing that very thing flying around the
world and doing the things which you
aren't allowed to do anymore yes people
aren't going to buy in yes and part of
the problem is people are thinking of it
as a green revolution
because the thing that they would most
hate is for us to solve a problem of
climate change
to create a world that looks exactly
like it does right now right without
climate change this is what i was going
to ask him alan because i tell you what
i see in it as well
there is a kind a broader thing going on
in western society which partly i cover
in my book which is there's a sort of
self-loathing in the west and i the
reason i think a lot of people feel
quite antagonistic to this green [ __ ] is
that
it's like you want people to suffer you
want to take away from people the things
that they enjoy because we are bad
because of colonialism and
industrialization and whatever else that
the west has you want us to suffer for
that and this is your punishment we're
going to raise your energy prices you're
not going to have any meat you're not
going to travel anywhere there's a sort
of like they love that [ __ ] they love to
to to feel like they're taking things
away from people that we must be
punished for our sins i think it feels
like that to a lot of people you know
and kova did as well and covered the
same yes but
the important thing is not to confuse
that mindset which is alive and well in
the heads of the extreme environmental
campaigners
and then a number of other mouthpieces i
mean you will see echoes of that in
various places definitely
you still have to divorce that from the
actual core science that says yeah we
still have a pragmatic problem that we
have to do something about
and the challenge is always when people
conflate the two because it's very easy
to fight back against that mindset yeah
you're right and to believe that then
that's fine but i'm with you i'm like
look if you need if you want to raise my
taxes to invest in better nuclear energy
go for it if you want to raise my taxes
to make sure that the energy we use is
used efficiently we're not wasting like
to me resource depletion is a big
problem pollution is a massive problem
go go for it i i'm happy to to pay more
money if that's what i need to do for
those things to be addressed i what i
don't like though is that tinge of
punitive action for the sins of my
forbearers i don't know
and i think
maybe you're right it's about the way
it's being marketed perhaps yes yes and
it's the sense that as we said earlier
on that all the communications in our
campaign communications and of course
and we've seen this finesse for fine art
with the pandemic with the
the use of a nudge unit to manipulate us
gently and subtly to complying
and this is a real problem because
they've already started producing
documents
looking at well how do you start to
nudge people into the right behaviors on
climate change now in the one sense it's
a fair question and discussion to have
to say well
if people are if people's behaviors are
less than optimal for themselves how how
would you encourage them to address that
how would you encourage to change that
you know if if a higher percentage of
america is obese than
really should be the case and is the
case anywhere else why is that and and
actually telling them that they're
dreadful people and they should change
probably isn't going to work so what
would work asking the question of how
you persuade people that's one thing
but manipulating them in a way that they
don't even notice you're doing
marketers do it all the time but there's
got to be a line
now marketers do it all the time you go
into a supermarket
you probably won't even notice there's a
smell of freshly baked bread in the air
and it won't occur to you that there's
no bakery in that supermarket because
they've worked out but if there's a bat
lovely scent or freshly ground coffee
people buy more
and they're subtly influencing you to
buy more okay so we know that corporates
are sort of borderline evil but at the
end of the day that is relatively
harmless relatively harmless i don't
mind that particularly maybe some people
do but if you're going to go to a
different supermarket if you want or not
shop in supermarkets you can't go to a
different country not really no that's
true but but you go into a supermarket
you don't know that's what they're doing
you know it's all very subliminal in
that sort of sense but if they're going
to use subliminal techniques to scare
you because
of the pandemic and they want you to
stay at home
and then suddenly everyone is so
terrified they want the government to
lock down again and so the government
locks down again because that's what
everybody wants but everybody wanted it
because the government scared them in
the first place
what the heck is going on with that if
you're going to do that with climate
change then yes you are going to have
populist reaction and deservedly so
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
you know i said to roger hallam uh we
were joking about you know
my time in my peace movement days and
you know
lots of
and my colleagues were in jail like he's
going to jail now he's still oh malin
you should get back into that i said
let's find roger when you take over i'll
be in jail soon enough
i absolutely hold to that where we are
going um the rise of
the soft authoritarianism
of of ultimately where this takes you
there are some real confrontations
coming
and
that's such a good point because there
is i remember talking with a friend who
was conspiratorial in nature and i was
at the start of the pandemic i'd say is
a conspiracy theorist but now he just
looks like he's sort of a prophet if i'm
going to be honest with you and he
actually said to me can you imagine in
five years or 10 years or maybe even 20
years can you rule out lockdowns for
climate change
and then i thought about it and i was
gonna scoff it and i thought
after everything that's happened i
genuinely can't
yeah i i think i still would i'm still
holding on to reality by my fingernails
i i think that's what i think i'm doing
anyway
[Music]
largely because
it's such a slow burn thing it wouldn't
make sense
now okay
there's quite a lot of things that we've
done over the last couple of years that
didn't necessarily make sense but
nevertheless with a with a virus with a
pandemic it is demonstrably a short-term
thing you get short-term waves and so on
but there is nothing to do with the
release of co2 into the atmosphere but
he's that short term where locking down
is going to make a huge amount of
difference and he didn't well lockdown
is a word what you could say is and by
the way i'm not his conspiratorially
minded friend i'm just playing devil's
advocate here but you could say
look you know there's no lockdown you
just you can only drive a certain number
of miles a year without a special permit
and you can only have one flight a year
unless you're going to visit a a family
member who's on their deathbed or for a
funeral or you can only have x number of
kilograms of beef chicken pork whatever
a year
like
all we're really talking about is
restricting people's freedom to do what
they think is the right thing for them
based on the argument that we've got you
know yes well that vision that vision is
definitely a possibility
and
right for me this is
absolutely no i think it's a possibility
in the same way
can i have that spliff now please
at least i'll feel better about it
the alternative possibility uh on the
other wing is the trumpian future where
the populist backlash means that we say
sod all that we don't believe any of it
anyway so we're just going to you know
burn
while we can
and there is somewhere in the middle on
all of this but ultimately if the middle
bit fails if the center fails to hold as
they say one of those two is the
extremes we can lurch to and maybe we'll
lurch to the one and then in reaction to
that we'll end up being pulled back to
the other but ultimately
the game is to avoid either
and that means
really trying to bring us back to
away from the polarized state that we've
becoming back to the sensible center
this country
used to run
does it still run i think it still runs
i'm not sure anymore it used to run on
the center
because our electoral system works so we
vote for a government they get in
there's a lot of counter evidence to
that lately i have to say but you're
you're right you're absolutely right
because they govern
i'm just joking you're absolutely
correct and then if they mess it up we
can then boot them out yes now that
pushes people back to the center yes by
and large and and the various parties
their fortunes have risen and fallen
when they've tacked to the center and
when they've been competent and most of
the elections have been fought and lost
on competence
every now and then we'll get one where
we've got two incompetents so that
doesn't happen that often
whereas in america um
they can't govern
they've got gridlock so bad that
basically whoever gets in they're not
really governing at all so they never
have consequences because they can
always point to the other side and say
we would have done great things but they
stopped us
and that therefore has created the
incentive for them drift further and
further to the extremes
whereas if you were able to govern if
biden was was elected i said okay you
run the government you want to do stupid
stuff
you can do it you're the government now
and that would
that would actually sort them out pretty
quickly because then they will be held
accountable for their actions
and that would be a very sobering thing
now we we have had that i think over the
last few decades
are we still there i don't know the
brexit
non-brexit dynamic the populist movement
stuff
it's it's very hard to see where our
core now is
but if it's still there as i think it is
then there's everything to play for in
tackling to the center the problem is we
have a government that won't fight for
its vision
when margaret thatcher first talked
about climate change she argued the case
why conservatives were the natural home
for those who care about the environment
and you could agree with our cases she
could not but she put forward a
conservative case why they were better
on the environment
and the labour party would put forward
their case while they were better and
you understood the visions that were
being put forward
what vision has the current government
got around net zero well that's more
vision as the current government go
around anything it's because you don't
have any margaret thatchers anymore
that's why so you've got the extremist
campaigners saying the world is going to
end and we have to do all this stuff
who's arguing with them when i was there
arguing for nuclear disarmament in my
naive charming way the government was
saying don't do what he said he's an
idiot
and they were kind of right although i
had a point as well
but they put the case they made the
argument they said if we don't address
this argument and explain why we need to
do what we need to do the public won't
understand why we're doing it
and we're just simply not doing that the
conservative government has no
conservative vision for net zero
so the conservatives in the party are
saying
what's this net zero stuff about this
isn't conservative and then the people
on the outside are looking at extinction
rebellion and they're thinking well
that's what net zero must be about and
that's one of the reasons why people are
conflating the science with the extreme
campaign solution and the problem is as
well is if a government doesn't have a
clear vision then it gives credence to
all the nutters at the far left and far
right well i think that was the point
that you were making exactly and this is
like i said if if if you had a
government whether they were laboratory
frankly when look we've got this problem
the science is pretty clear we've got
this problem uh that's looming we need
to invest in technology to to solve this
problem right and that's why
a portion of our budget will go towards
what is the best form of nuclear energy
how do we get wind and solar how do we
design better batteries elon musk here
is a grant whatever right
what sensible person would go no
actually i think this is all bollocks
i i don't think anyone would i mean some
people would of course but the vast
majority of people would be like well
okay that's fair enough i mean we spend
a billion here a billion now and other
stuff if we threw a few billion at
finding new technology that's going to
is going to address some of these issues
but that isn't the way the
conversation's been had and you're right
it is on the government because they're
not engaging aggressively yes with this
nonsense and going look we think the
climate is important and here's our plan
to deal with it and greta thundberg
needs to go back to school
right if they did that you would have a
much easier time of convincing people to
get support behind the cause yes
absolutely and of course greta is now
old enough to be wrong so
this is interesting
at the cop 26 conference she was the
first time when she wasn't invited onto
the main platform you'll have noticed
and she said her usual thing about oh
they're all going blah blah blah and
they're not doing anything and the first
time there were news stories appearing
saying gret he was very gentle and he
was very respectful but he's saying
actually we think greta might be wrong
about race i thought well she's come of
age
she would say whatever she liked before
and people found it charming but if
you're these people in that conference
hall who have been working and slaving
trying to make this thing work trying to
make you know he's really genuinely
difficult what we are trying to do has
never been done before it is incredibly
difficult and they're getting make it
make mistakes and get it wrong and do
all sorts of things nevertheless they've
been really trying to do it having
someone say what you do equals nothing
charming when they're 15 not so much
when they're 19
which is why she's outside the
conference because that's where
outsiders live
and and it's up to her because they
would let her in as part of a process
but you have to stop being an outsider
if you're going to do that and she can't
do it because she's become part of that
extreme campaign
group community
and their messages are not the messages
of the insiders trying to to work
solutions they're not interested in
solutions what is extinction rebellion
wants to happen
they can't tell you they won't tell you
yeah they won't point at a policy
because there are no policies that would
deliver
zero emissions in five years that
wouldn't throw
hundreds upon hundreds of millions of
people into poverty
again if you were looking at it as a
multi-variable problem
you would have way more people dying if
you did what they say of course then
climate change would ever be killing
poverty has killed way more people
through history
malin what would you say to this
argument and i'm not for extinction
rebellion at all but what they have done
is they've brought this issue into the
forefront of everyone's minds
they've publicized it we now talk about
it they're on the front page of every
newspaper isn't there something to be
said for that
not really it's
that's largely recency bias we were
talking about it before
we were go back and look we were talking
about this
already to to the point of nauseam
before this happened
and it's the same with any campaigning
movement yeah i was in the peace
movement when they got rid of nuclear
cruise missiles the people in the
campaign was ah we did that
and i looked at it i thought
no we didn't there was always
geopolitics as to why that happened and
then ultimately the soviet union
collapsed because we outspent them there
were those dynamics that led to that
outcome peace movement actually had very
little to do with it
they kept the issues alive in the
general population if that was a vehicle
for change
in that particular instance then yeah
that would have been fine but it wasn't
and it isn't
so in this case
constantly reminding people about
climate change
how does that help
particularly the government was already
working on the committee on climate
change process
that predated uh extinction rebellion
forming they produced their report then
after they just started and the
government said yep we we will sign up
to that report there's been three years
in the making and extinction rebellion
said yes we did that that you didn't
no you didn't not at all now look i i
don't want to decry it because i was
there and most of the people who sign up
to the movement are doing it because
they're scared for the future and that's
not an irrational thing to be
you know you can be pushed too far with
that nevertheless as a young person it's
correct to be concerned
and they just want to do something and
and to be heard
that doesn't go for the likes of you
know the political activists behind the
movement and you know i interviewed
roger and you know he's a very nice
amiable guy but you know he is a
political activist he's a far far-left
activist who wants to overthrow
overstate
hasn't got a hope in hell of doing it
but nevertheless that's his modus
operandi
that ain't going to create the sort of
change that is going to make anyone's
lives any better
and i think the sooner you call that out
and say yes the issue is important but
this process that was going on before
isn't being pushed by that movement per
se then we can start to have sensible
conversations about what actually needs
to change because what they are doing is
distracting attention they're saying
something big needs to happen
and something is already happening and
the question is no one's paying
attention
and holding that accountable
because they're
involved with this cartoon level
discussion that's going on over here so
every moment the government isn't being
held accountable for net zero why is
that because none of the opposition
parties
disagree with the objective of net zero
and because all communications are now
campaign communications they won't
criticize them on this because it won't
be helpful
now that's not how political opposition
is supposed to work the only people who
are providing real political opposition
at the moment are
the anti-net zero people the people who
wouldn't do any of it at all um who have
done things like uh demanding the
committee on climate change release
their uh costings
for their programme and they refused to
do it so they took them to court and
they were able to say well look some of
these figures don't add up
and that should be happening because of
course they're probably
cutting corners and doing things that
people do when they think no one's
looking because that's what happens
that's not a political thing it just
happens bureaucracy politics everyone
gets away with what they think they'll
get away with that's why you have
scrutiny
and so
if the political parties are not going
to scrutinize the government on this
area because it's all campaign messaging
that is a real problem for us and then
extinction rebellion are over there
saying well we need to overthrow over
government doesn't actually help that
conversation at all i don't know man the
longer the [ __ ] goes on the more i start
to agree with them
but melon it's been an absolute pleasure
really genuinely and to have this
conversation from from a sensible
perspective is quite reassuring frankly
uh in some ways so thank you for coming
on uh before we ask uh not only our last
question on the interview but also our
special questions for locals tell
everybody where they can find your work
online and follow up on this chat and
and and find more of the things that
you're putting out there so most of my
content goes on to my youtube channel if
you just simply search on youtube from
alan baker
that will come up
and i also have a website at
malinbaker.net
and then little bits dribble out there
and there i'm on twitter at malindbaker
thank you very much malin before we go
uh to our local questions we always have
our one final question which is what's
the one thing we're not talking about
but we really should be
well it's i think that we're spoiled for
choice to be honest i'm going to give
you two quick ones rather than just for
one so
one quick one is
how different the economic dynamic is
going to be as we move on to a stable or
declining population base
our
thriving economy of the last 50 to 100
years have been based on a rapidly
increasing population
already you know with china because they
don't allow a huge amount of immigration
they're now suddenly confronting
the real constraints that a stable
population is going to throw they are an
emerging superpower they're about to
overtake america and suddenly they're
bumping in to this demographic real
issue
and now it's going to change all these
equations yeah it's all very well bjorn
lombol coming on here and saying well of
course in 100 years with the economic
growth is going to be happening yeah but
all of that is based on what happened in
the past and what's coming in the future
is demonstrably going to be different
because we can't negotiate our way
around that we can't have 20 billion
people in a hundred years so that is
going to make a big difference the other
thing i would say
is the huge difference
that the emergence of artificial
intelligence is going to make on the
battlefield
so military technology with artificial
intelligence
is pushing us
logically into where we were 30 years
ago with nuclear weapons
it's just that it will be very easy for
us to miss the fact
that we've entered a new paradigm of
destruction
before we unleash it
you know with nuclear weapons we worked
out very quickly
that this had achieved the scale
where the disincentive to use them
kicked in you know generally if we had
it we used it and it kicked in to say ah
no maybe we shouldn't we nearly did we
came very close but we didn't
artificial intelligence on the
battlefield is going to the same
singularity particularly what the
chinese want to do
which is
to use artificial intelligence to mean
that things move too fast for humans to
keep up with to understand what's going
on
you know the west is saying we do not
want that to happen we always want a
human decision maker to be the one who
decides whether somebody dies
you do not want ai making that decision
the chinese are saying well that's for
wusses the whole power of ai is going to
be that it can think a lot faster than
human beings ever can
and you start to build that into a swarm
of a thousand tiny drones all sorts of
things that can completely change the
nature of what we think of as a balance
of power in the world as we understand
it at the moment
we should probably be talking about that
a little bit more than we are
yeah it's great it's basically like
youtube's algorithm with drugs
that's what you want yeah fantastic
exactly malin it's been an absolute
pleasure i'm sure we'll have you back to
talk about more stuff uh we've got to
wrap up here though so thank you for
being here and thank you for watching
and listening we will see you very soon
with another brilliant interview like
this one or all show all of them go out
at 7 pm uk time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
state level communism has been terrible
for the environment by and large
whenever it's been pushed to scale